china china china this other blockbuster
story rocking capitol hill a democratic
member of congress
possibly compromised by a chinese spy a
woman
lawmakers demanding answers congressman
eric swalwell at the center
of what could be a massive scandal for
his ties to this uh chinese spy
she really worked for their their spy
agency targeting
him and other democrats sometimes using
sex to influence
these american politicians carson
swalwell not only denying any wrongdoing
he's trying to blame president trump for
this story coming out
the wrong doing here jim is that at the
same time this story was being leaked
out
is the time that i was working on
impeachment on the house intelligence
and judiciary committees
and if this is a country where people
who criticize the president are going to
have law enforcement
information weaponized against them
that's not a country that any of us want
to live in and i hope it is investigated
as to
who leaked this information who leaked
the information how about what you did
uh house minority leader kevin mccarthy
is not buying
swalwell's explanation of being
entrapped he wants walwell
off the house intelligence committee so
i want to go dana purno you're a very
nice person
these are chinese spies that go down to
the level of a mayor
they they court and help a city council
member
become a congressman this congressman
now gets
on the intel committee why is he still
on the intel committee let known why is
he still a member of congress
did adam schiff know as chairman of that
committee
that he had this problem
ahead democrats admit putting politics
over people i'll get right to that but
dana here's a quote from chris ray the
fbi director
china is engaged in a highly
sophisticated malign
foreign influence campaign they're using
uh you know fang fang this woman to uh
to entrap she had sex with a couple of
mayors
i i never liked swalwell
because he's such a smarmy person but
does he have any uh
any juice and when he uh when he says
that this is all
uh trying to get him because he went
after trump for
impeachment well first of all they had
48
hours to actually like come up with a
better excuse than
trump campaign or somebody in the trump
administration is leaking this to hurt
me
i just logically think that if somebody
were going to leak this they would have
done it during impeachment um and not
only during impeachment but what was
happening just a few months before that
does
anyone remember eric swalwell threw his
hat in the ring to run for president
and so this information i would imagine
was going to come out
at some point like if is he that
blind to how this all works that he
thinks that he could run for president
and this information wouldn't come out
now whether the
like for speaker pelosi or adam schiff
if they knew about this
and didn't care and put him on the intel
committee instead of putting him on the
rules committee or something like that
where
maybe his uh pass wouldn't have come up
that would be one thing
i think that this is just extremely
problematic again
he's lucky that hunter biden is taking
the headlines right now but
we haven't seen the end of the story and
i don't think that it's going to cut it
for him to blame
leaks on the trump administration i
totally agree with that
greg i know how paranoid you are about
china
but you know that doesn't make you wrong
i think china china china they're trying
everything
whether it's the honey pot or jewels
under the pillow they'll do anything to
get
uh influence how scary is it greg
um first off her name is fang fang that
should have tipped you off about sinking
her teeth into you
although i think she's the real victim
if she had to hook up with swat well
but think about this while schwalwell
mocked trump for raising concerns about
china china he knew was compromising him
so why did swalwell do this why did
swahwell push the russian hysteria story
because he wanted to get it away from
him so he was actually pushing a lot of
this stuff that's my opinion
but now this is what this is really
important
now you see why trump was so despised by
the media politicians academia the tech
giants
he stood between them and china he was
the first to call out this threat
and he had to go so this is another
weird thing
that trump was right he called them out
and he was demonized for it early on
people mocked him when he said china
china china and again
where are all the woodward and
bernstein's they were too busy
cataloging tweets to do their job we
this is actually a massive story you
have compromised americans
you have them defending china and now
you have china ecstatic that joe's
in the white house seems to me that
would be something good for
somebody to win a pulitzer for instead
of just chasing tweets
i i think you're uh you're you know
it's a fanciful notion that the press
will work as hard to
investigate the biden family as they did
to wreck
the trump the trump family but judge
janine you have a situation here where
china really
is this malignancy now and i have
nothing against
obviously this isn't about chinese
people this is about the communist party
that runs the uh the the richest nation
on earth right now
judge well you know the the hypocrisy
of it all just makes me crazy you know
eric swalwell
who's complaining about donald trump and
all this that trump is a russian
asset and a putin puppet he gets a
warning he gets the fbi to tell him look
fong fang whatever her name is
you know she is she is part of an uh a
communist chinese
intelligence group the president they
try to impeach him
you know the president's kids get
investigated i want swalwell
investigated
i want to know what he said what did she
tell him and i don't want him to get
away with some stupid
answer like i can't engage in this story
right now
because it may involve classified
information hogwash the trumps were put
through hell for four years
this is real the russia collusion
delusion was a delusion
china with the culture centers with
infiltrating people in this country
they are a danger to this country as
hunter
and they access people with egos like
swalwell who think he can be the
president of the united states
that's who they're giving money to and
that's who they're playing with or
sleeping with
whatever whatever jesse what about him
being the real manchurian
candidate
yeah i don't i don't buy that i i don't
think he's a chinese agent i just think
he's a fool
i mean the guy had a chinese spy
put an intern into his congressional
office do you know how
the things you can access at a
congressional office
i interned with joe lieberman in college
i had access to
lots of stuff i shouldn't have access to
god knows what they found
but i want to be fair to him in a little
respect but when someone says
did you sleep with a spy and your answer
is
it's classified you probably slept with
the spot
maybe maybe he's a little shaky because
the spy
slept with a couple other politicians
but it's humiliating
and the fact that they put a compromised
guy open to blackmail on the house intel
committee
could you imagine if devin nunes was
sleeping with a russian spy
and the gop knew about it and had him
running house intel
that's crazy the only thing i don't
understand is and judge
hit on this perfectly how come the fbi
didn't
frame swalwell for colluding with the
chinese
how come they didn't want to stop
you know they made the they made that
russia thing last for three and a half
years and
and try to destroy trump now they have
this this is gigantic